- On a dans nos classes, qui
nous arrivent du secondaire,
puis c'est fort comme
expression, mais des
analphabètes fonctionnels.
Qui ont de la difficulté
à percevoir l'ironie par
exemple, le sens figuré.
- Les étudiants sont mal équipés
pour rentrer dans un texte,
décortiquer, analyser un texte.
- T'sais là, "vraiment"
il vient accompagner le "son".
- Comme certains ont la bosse
des mathdes mathdes maths, Chloe
la facilité en francais.
Alors, elle accompagne d'autres
étudiants au CAF, le Centre
d'aide en Francais.- J'en aide ,
donc c'est une heure par eleve
- C'est au cégep Edouard
Montpetit qu'est né le premier
CAF, il y a 35 ans. L'aide q
y donne  est plus essentielle
que jamais. Jacob Lizotte
apprend à corriger ses textes.e.
JACOB LIZOTTE , étudiant, cégep
Édouard-Montpetit
- À la base, j'ai un problème de
dyslexie. C'est la facon, donc,
que je vais relire mes textes,
je vais être plus minutieux,
je vais relire phrase par phrase
pour bien m'assurer que
la syntala syntala syntala synt.
- Même chez ceux qui n'ont pas
de troubles spécifiques,
la jeune tutrice constate
un problème avec les
connaissances de bases chez
ses camarades et un certain
décalage.
CHLOÉ ST-PIERRE, tutrice au CAF
cégep Édouard-Montpetit
- En faisant le tutorat,
j'avoue que j'ai été surprise
par certains de mes élèves,
le niveau de francais. Moi,
je me suis toujours dit quand
on arrive au cégep, on a atteint
un certain niveau de langue.
- Il n'y a pas que l'orthographe
et la syntaxe qui préoccupent
les professeurs de littérature
ilosophie au collégial.
Anne-Marie Tézine, prof de litt.
cégep Edouard Montpetit
- Je vois des difficultés sur
le plan de la lecture. Je pense
que les générations qui ont
grandi avec les réseaux sociaux,
la technologie, internet et tout
ça, je pense qu'ils ont plus
de difficulté à lire des longs
plus ardus. C'est plus
dififcile aujourd'hui de mettre
au programme "Notre-Dame de
Paris" ou "Madame Bovary"
que ça l'était, il y 30 ans.- CF
du cégep Édouard-Montpetit
suit près de 300 étudiants.
NICOLAS CHALIFOUR, prof de litt.
cégep Édouard-Montpetit
- C'est terrible à 17 ans alors
qu'on a une grille de sept
cours, qu'on arrive au cégep et
là, en plus, de devoir faire un
espece de rattrapage de ce qui
aurait dû se faire de manière
répétée et compulstttttt
11 ans. L'apprentissage
de la langue, c'est ca là.
Faudrait que les étudiants qui
arrivent au cégep sachent lire
et écrire, soient
de s'exprimer et soit capable
de s'exprimer dans une langue
soutenue.
RÉJEAN BERGERON, professeur de
philosop Gérald-Godin
- Les etudiants arrivent
au cégep avec des trous,
des manques. Je ne parle pas des
exceptions dans l'accord du
e passé oue passé oue passé oues
byzantines, non. C'est vraiment
des choses essentielles qui
viennent faire en sorte
qu'on puisse comprendre
. Confondre un pronom
possessif et un pronom
démonstratif, ça change
le sens du texte.
PASCALE LEFRANÇOIS, doyenne,sciM
- On doit écrire davantage qu'on
devait écrire il y a 20, 30 ou
40 ans, alors, il faudrait
normalement être meilleurs en
écriture qu'il y a 20, 30 ou
40 ans.
- Pour celle qui dirige
la faculté des sciences de
l'Éducation de l'Université
de Montréal, le problème c'est
que la maîtrise du francais
ne s'améliore pas.
- On peut obtenir son diplôme
d'études secondaire en
commettant 28 erreurs dans
un texte de 500 mots. Donc,
si on veut s'améliorer, il y a
vraiment de la place, il me
semble, là. On sait que le
élèves sont plutôt doués pour
organiser leurs idées dans un
texte et mettre un contenu
approprié. Là où le bât blesse,
c'est vraiment la
de la langue, plus
spécifiquement l'orthographe.
À l'université comme au cégep,
les étudiants doivent mettre
en application les règles et
les connaissances acquises
au primaire et au secondaire.
- Un verbe peut avoir plusie
constructions différentes.
- Le département de linguistique
de l'UQAM offre plusieurs cours
de perfectionnement du francais
aux étudiants insc
programmes et aux étudiants
libres.
JOANIE FOREST, étudiante libre
Université du Québec à Mon
- Dans mon cas, c'est du
rattrappage puis il y a des
choses que j'apprends en ce
moment que j'apprends
différemment ou qu
du tout appris quand que j'étais
jeune.
KARINE LACROIX-CUERRIER, prof.
linguistique UQAM
- On me
avait beaucoup de notions qui
avaient été soit pas vues ou
oubliées depuis le secondaire.
Par exemple, la subordonnée
relative, la chose dont je
parle. Pourquoi est-ce que
e : la chose
que je parle.
- Il faut les outiller,
les étudiants, à tirer profit
des ouvrages de reference,
j'inclus le correcteur là-
dedans, pour être capablerer lee
poser les bonnes questions quand
ils écrivent. On adore
les dictionnaires, nous les
professeurs de francais, parce
qu'ils nous aident réellement
reurs. Et on
en apprend tous les jours, même
quand on est professeur de
français depuis longtemps.
- Les étudiants forts sont jours
aussi forts, probablement plus
forts, mais c'est le milieuon le
qui perd du terrain.port commana
Ministre Danielle McCann en
septembre sur la maitrise du
francais aux études supérieures
risque de décevoir le milieu,
s'il ne porte pas aussi sur
l'enseignement du francais
au primaire et au secondaire